Es útil hacer una función invertible a partir de una
que no es invertible al restringir su dominio.
La gráfica de "f" de "x" se muestra a continuación.
Es esta de aquí.
¿A qué intervalos podríamos restringir "f" de "x"
para obtener una función invertible?
Y bueno, es que recuerda
que cuando buscamos una función invertible,
la relación inversa tiene que ser una función bien definida.
¿A qué me refiero con eso?
Bueno, primeramente, déjame mostrarte que ésta
es una función que no es invertible.
Y hay varias maneras de hacer eso.
Lo primero es que "f", esta función,
es una función de una manera clara,
si nosotros nos fijamos
en la prueba de la recta vertical,
si yo por ejemplo, aquí,
trazo una recta vertical
aunque se vea más o menos así,
me tomo una recta vertical, más o menos como ésta,
ésta de aquí, va a ser mi recta vertical, ok,
entonces, date cuenta que se intersecta
solamente en un punto,
en este punto de aquí,
y es más,
déjame cambiar a un color un poco más fuerte,
para que lo veas una manera más clara,
en este caso, esta recta vertical,
y es más, déjenme hacerle así,
esta recta vertical, intersecta a la función
en solo un punto, en este punto de aquí.
Ahora, ten cuidado,
seguramente te estás preguntando,
¿por qué esto nos ayuda a ver
que ésta es una función?
pero es que,
imagínate que no intersectara en sólo un punto,
imagínate que tuviéramos algo así,
una función que baja
y aquí otra vez va a tomar un cierto valor,
va a bajar o no...
espera, déjame cambiar de herramienta...
y entonces va a tomar un cierto valor para esto...
así,
y se ve como una relación como ésta.
Bueno, pues date cuenta que en este momento,
la recta vertical toca a dos puntos,
pero como está tocando a dos puntos,
entonces ¿qué pasa para esta "x" que tenemos aquí? para "x" igual a 7,
para "x" igual a 7 ¿cuál es su valor?
es ,3 su valor,
o es -3 su valor.
En este momento,
no estamos mapeando a esta "x"
a un único valor y por lo tanto,
no sabríamos cuánto vale el valor de "x" igual a 7,
lo cual como sabemos, no es una función,
y es por eso que nos sirve la prueba de la recta vertical,
para saber si esta gráfica es una función.
Pero bueno déjame quitar todo esto, porque ahora vamos a utilizar la prueba de la recta ya no vertical
sino en este caso vamos a utilizar,
la prueba de la recta horizontal.
Y esto, nos va a servir
para ver si la función es invertible.
La prueba de la recta horizontal, nos va a servir para ver
si la función es invertirle o no,
y es que una forma de ver esto,
es que vamos a intercambiar los valores de "x" y de "y"
porque entonces la gráfica de la función,
se vería más o menos así si los intercambiamos
Imagínate que esto lo voy a voltear
y me va a quedar algo así
y voy a pasar por... este punto...
voy a pasar por este punto
y entonces me quedaría,
algo más o menos así, ok,
y después aquí empezaríamos en este...
y vamos a pasar por este punto...
y me quedaría algo más o menos así,
ok, ésta sería intercambiar
los valores de "x" por los valores de "y"
y bueno, aquí justo en este valor tomaría este punto
y entonces yo me regreso 1, 2, 3, 4
aquí... aquí empezaría
y pasaría algo más o menos así,
y bueno, de igual manera para acá,
aquí tomaría este valor
y entonces si yo me regreso 4...
entonces pasaría algo más o menos, así.
Así se vería si intercambiáramos los valores,
pero date cuenta, que en este caso,
no pasa de una manera clara
la prueba de la recta vertical, si te das cuenta,
en este momento tenemos una recta vertical
y tocamos muchos valores,
tocamos este valor de aquí,
este valor de aquí, este valor de aquí
y este valor de aquí y por lo tanto,
no estamos pasando la prueba de la recta vertical.
Ahora, otra forma de verlo,
sería desde un principio aplicar la prueba de la recta,
pero en este caso,
me voy a tomar la recta horizontal,
en este caso me voy a tomar la recta horizontal
y se vería más o menos así,
si yo me fijo en una recta horizontal,
por aquí, por ejemplo,
date cuenta que tocamos a varios puntos,
tocamos...
y déjame poner con este color, a este punto de aquí
a este punto de aquí, a este punto de aquí,
a este punto de aquí y entonces estamos hablando
de una función que no es invertible.
Nuestra prueba de la recta horizontal
claramente está fallando,
y una vez más,
¿por qué esto prueba que no es invertible ?
Bueno, porque estamos interceptando a la recta
en varios puntos
y ¿por qué esto es un problema?
Bueno, recordemos un poco,
¿qué debería de cumplir una función y su función de inversa?
Si yo tengo por ejemplo aquí...
vamos a ponerlo justo aquí,
tengo aquí el dominio de esta función
y déjame ponerlo así,
aquí tengo el dominio...
dominio, ok,
y por acá me voy a tomar el codominio...
por acá me voy a tomar al codominio...
codominio...
Bueno, pues date cuenta de lo siguiente,
si yo me tomo el valor de 4,
me da el valor de 4,
así que si aquí en el dominio,
me tomo el valor de 4,
bueno, pues después de aplicar la función,
"f" de 4, me va a dar 4 en este caso,
en la función mapea al 4, al 4,
esto en la función.
Ahora si yo me tomo por ejemplo el 9,
el 9 también lo mapea al 4,
por lo tanto, lo voy a poner así,
"f" de 9, bueno, después de que apliquemos la función,
me da también 4, de lujo.
Ahora, si nosotros pensamos en la relación inversa,
¿qué es lo que va a pasar?
Recuerda que la función inversa
va a tomar elementos del codominio
y los va a mapear con elementos del dominio.
Pero en este caso,
¿cuánto valdría "f" inversa de 4?
¿Cuánto valdría "f" inversa de 4?
Valdría 4, nos regresaríamos al valor de 4,
o en su dado caso "f" inversa de 4,
no... me regresaría en este caso al 9,
¿a cuál de los dos valores voy a dar?
y es justo el problema
"f" inversa no sabemos si me regresa al 4...
no sabemos si me regresa al 4...
o en su dado caso me regresa al 9
y por lo tanto estamos encontrando un grave problema
una relación que no va uno a uno
y éste es justo el problema cuando tenemos
varios elementos del dominio,
que se mapean a un mismo elemento del codominio,
esto está bien en un principio para hacer una función.
Un elemento del dominio,
lo mapea a un elemento del condominio.
Pero ahora, esto nos va a traer un problema
para que la relación de inversa sea una función,
y en este caso nos da una función que no es invertible.
Así que esencialmente lo que vamos a hacer
es averiguar en qué intervalo podemos restringir la función
para obtener una función invertible.
Estos intervalos deben de pasar
la prueba de la recta horizontal,
para cada miembro del intervalo que nos vamos a tomar,
se deben de cumplir que todos sus valores
se maten a valores distintos de su codominio,
un mapeo uno a uno,
entre los miembros del dominio restringido,
y del potencial codominio restringido.
Así que veamos estos distintos dominios restringidos,
para ver qué es lo que pasa.
Qué te parece si empezamos con el primero,
-10, 0 y es un intervalo abierto,
así que -10 está como por aquí
tenemos un intervalo abierto...
déjame cambiar de color....
y es más, déjame limpiar esto
para que podamos trabajar en orden.
Vamos a quitar esto de aquí, ok,
entonces déjame tomar otro color...
este color de aquí...
Aquí va a empezar un intervalo,
está abierto y vamos hasta el 0,
y si te das cuenta, justo aquí,
no pasa la prueba de la recta vertical.
por ejemplo,
aquí tomamos un valor para "y" dos veces,
aquí y acá...
y por lo tanto, aunque este intervalo,
parecía ser un buen intervalo,
no es un intervalo en el cual podemos restringir la función, para obtener una función invertible,
ya que tenemos valores repetidos para "y",
para algunos valores para "x",
por ejemplo aquí -9 y 2,
y aquí -4 y 2,
por lo tanto, éste, en definitiva,
no pasa la prueba de la recta horizontal.
veamos este otro -10, 5 abierto,
todos los intervalos son abiertos,
así que vamos a ver este otro,
déjame quitar esto de aquí, vamos a quitar esto de aquí
y vamos a ver el siguiente
-10, -5...
-10, -5
y es un intervalo abierto,
así que vamos a ponerlo así,
-10 está abierto,
-5 está también abierto
y si te das cuenta, este intervalo se cumple,
porque si nos fijamos aquí,
cualquier recta horizontal que nos tomemos
solamente va a tocar a un punto en esta gráfica,
solamente va a tocar
a un único punto en esta gráfica
y esto es, porque tenemos un intervalo abierto,
así que no volvemos a tocar este punto,
tenemos desde aquí, hasta acá,
todos los valores
y además porque esta gráfica si es invertible,
este pedazo de gráfica si es invertible y es  más,
lo podemos visualizar de la siguiente manera.
Si nosotros nos fijamos en esta función de aquí
y ahora me tomo la función inversa,
bueno, pues date cuenta que ahora
voy a estar en el punto -10, 0
lo voy a pasar al 0, -10...
al 0, -10
estaría por aquí pero lo voy a poner abierto
y aquí en el 5...
en el -5, 0 lo voy a pasar al 0, -5
aquí voy a tener un intervalo abierto
y bueno aquí cerca en el -6, 4
lo voy a pasar al 4, -6,
algo más o menos por aquí
y por aquí va a pasar mi función inversa,
se vería más o menos algo así,
que si te das cuenta, no es ni más ni menos,
que una reflexión bajo la recta,
"y" igual a "x"
si nos tomamos la recta "y"igual a "x",
date cuenta que en este momento
este pedazo de gráfica, es una reflexión
de este pedazo de gráfica y por eso,
sí podemos encontrar la función inversa
en ese intervalo abierto,
por lo tanto voy a poner que sí
este intervalo si funciona
y entonces le voy a poner una palomita.
Y le voy a poner una pequeña paloma porque
recuerda que pasó la prueba de la recta .vertical
Ahora, veamos el siguiente intervalo
-9, -4
-9 está aquí abierto, -4 está aquí abierto,
y si te das cuenta,
este también es un intervalo que nos va a servir.
Déjame borrar aquí todo esto para que lo veas con mayor claridad
si yo borro todo esto, ok,
vamos a ver si pasa
nuestra prueba de la recta vertical,
-9, el -9 está por aquí,
lo voy a poner abierto,
-4 está aquí lo voy a poner abierto
y si te das cuenta en este intervalo cualquier recta
que yo me tomé a horizontal,
solamente va a tocar a un punto,
éste toca a estos puntos de aquí,
estas rectas,
y después llega un punto en el que empieza a tocar
a la función en estos puntos de aquí...
en estos puntos de aquí...
A éste también le voy a poner una pequeña paloma,
éste también nos sirve.
Vamos a borrar todo esto de aquí...
Ok y ahora vamos a fijarnos
en el intervalo -10, -4
-10 está justo por aquí,
-4 está justo por aquí
y éste en definitiva no pasa esta prueba
porque si te das cuenta
aquí estoy encontrando una recta horizontal,
que toca dos de los puntos,
por lo tanto este intervalo, no nos va a servir,
y ahora vamos a fijarnos en el último intervalo,
-5, 0
entonces déjame quitar esto de aquí
y me voy a aplicar en el -5, 0
si te das cuenta el -5 está justo por aquí,
tenemos este punto, es un intervalo abierto
el 0 tenemos este punto, es un intervalo abierto
y si te das cuenta,
si yo trazo cualquier recta horizontal por aquí
este si funciona,
es decir,
cumple la prueba de la recta horizontal y por lo tanto,
lo voy a marcar como una opción correcta
porque ya pasó nuestra prueba,
y ya está.